the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
all right welcome to six triple zero two
or if you're in 600 the second half of
600 I'm John Guttag let me start with a
few administrative things
what's the workload there are problem
sets
they'll all be programming problems much
in the style of six triple zero one and
the goal really twofold six triple zero
one problem sets we're mostly about
learning to be a programmer a lot of
that carries over no one learns to be a
programmer in half a semester so a lot
of it is to improve your skills but also
there's a lot more I would say
conceptual algorithmic material in six
triple zero two and the problem sets are
designed to help cement that as well as
just to give you programming experience
finger exercises small things if they're
taking you more than 15 minutes let us
know they really shouldn't and they're
generally designed to help you learn a
single concept usually a programming
concept reading assignments in the
textbooks I've already posted the first
reading assignment and essentially they
should provide you a very different take
on the same material recovering in
lectures and recitations we've tried to
choose different examples for lectures
and from the textbooks for the most part
so you get to see things in to fight we
different ways there will be a final
exam based upon all of the above all
right prerequisites experience writing
object-oriented programs in Python
preferably Python 3.5 if familiarity
with concepts of computational
complexity you'll see even in today's
lecture will be assuming that
familiarity with some simple algorithms
if you took six triple zero one or you
took the six triple zero one advanced
standing exam you'll be fine
odds are you'll be fine anyway but
that's the safest way to do it so the
programming assignments are going to be
a bit easier at least that's what
students have reported in the past
because there'll be more focus on the
problem to be solved than on the actual
programming the lecture content more
abstract the lecturers will be and maybe
in speaking euphemistically a bit faster
paced so hang on to your seats and the
course is really less about programming
and more about dipping your toe into the
exotic world of data science we do want
you to hone your programming skills
there'll be a few additional bits of
Python today for example we'll talk
about lambda abstraction inevitably some
comments about software engineering how
to structure your code more emphasis in
using packages hopefully it will go a
little bit smoother than in the last
problem set in six triple zero one and
finally it's the old joke about
programming that somebody walks up to a
taxi driver in New York City and says
I'm lost how do I get to Carnegie Hall
the taxi driver turns to the person and
says practice practice practice and
that's really the only way to learn the
program is practice practice practice
the main topic of the course is what I
think of as computational models how do
we use computation to understand the
world in which we live what is a model
to me I think of it as an experimental
device that can help us to either
understand something that has happened
to sort of build a model that explains
phenomena we see every day or a model
that will allow us to predict the future
something that hasn't happened so you
can think of for example a climate
change model we can build models that
sort
explained how the climate has changed
over the millennia and then we can build
probably a slightly different model that
might predict what it will be like in
the future so essentially what's
happening is science is moving out of
the wet lab and into the computer
increasingly I'm sure you all see this
overview who are science majors an
increasing reliance on computation
rather than traditional experimentation
as we'll talk about a traditional
experimentation will is and will remain
important but now it has to really be
supplemented by computation well we'll
talk about three kinds of models
optimization models statistical models
and simulation models so let's talk
first about optimization models an
optimization model is a very simple
thing we start with an objective
function it's either to be maximized or
minimized for so for example if I'm
going from New York to Boston I might
want to find a route by car or plane or
train that minimizes the total travel
time so my objective function would be
the number of minutes spent in transit
getting from A to B we then often have
to layer on top of that objective
function a set of constraints
sometimes empty that we have to obey so
maybe the fastest way to get from New
York to Boston is to take a plane but I
only have $100 to spend so that option
is off the table
so either constraints they're on the
amount of money I can spend or maybe I
have to be in Boston before 5 p.m. and
while the bus would get me there before
for $15 it won't get me there before
5:00 and so maybe what I'm left with is
driving something like that so objective
function
something you're either minimizing or
maximizing and a set of constraints that
eliminate some solutions and as we'll
see there's an asymmetry here we candle
these two things differently we use
these things all the time I commute to
work using Waze which essentially is
solving not very well I believe an
optimization problem to minimize my time
from home to here when you travel maybe
you log in to two various advisory
programs that try and optimize things
for you they're all over the place today
you really can't avoid using an
optimization algorithm as you as you get
through life all right pretty abstract
let's talk about a specific optimization
problem called the knapsack problem the
first time I talked about the knapsack
problem I neglected to show a picture of
a knapsack and it was I was 10 minutes
into it before I realized most of the
class had no idea what a knapsack was
it's what we old people used to call a
backpack and they used to look more like
that than they look today so the
knapsack problem involves usually it's
told in terms of a burglar who breaks
into a house and wants to steal a bunch
of stuff but has a knapsack that will
only hold a finite amount of stuff that
he or she wishes to steal and so the
burglar has to solve the optimization
problem of stealing the stuff with the
most value while obeying the constraint
that it all has to fit in the knapsack
so we have an objective function
I'll get the most for this when I fence
it and a constraint it has to fit in my
backpack and you can guess which of
these might be the most valuable items
here
so here's in words written words what I
just said orally there's more stuff than
you can carry and you have to choose
which is up to take and which to leave
behind I should point out that there are
two variants of it there's the zero-one
knapsack problem and the continuous so
the 0 1 would be illustrated by
something like this so the zero-one
knapsack problem means you either take
the object or you don't I take that
whole goal bar or I take none of it
the continuous or so called fractional
knapsack problem says I can take pieces
of it so maybe if I take in my gold bar
and shaved it into gold dust I then can
say well the whole thing won't fit in
but I can fit in a path part of it the
continuous knapsack problem is really
boring it's easy to solve how do you
think you would solve a continuous
problem
suppose you had over here a pile of gold
and a pile of silver and a pile of
raisins and you wanted to maximize your
value
well you'd fill up your knapsack with
gold until you either ran out of gold or
ran out of space you haven't run out of
space you'll now put silver in until you
run out of space if you still haven't
run out of space well then you'll take
as many raisins as you can fit in but
you can solve it with what's called a
greedy algorithm and we'll talk much
more about this as we go forward where
you take the best thing first as long as
you can and then you move on to the next
thing as we'll see the zero-one knapsack
problem is much more complicated because
once you make a decision it will affect
the future decisions all right let's
look at an example and I should probably
warn you if you're hungry this is not
going to be a fun lecture so here's my
least favorite because I always want to
eat more than I'm supposed to eat so the
point is typically knapsack problems are
not physical knapsacks but some
conceptual idea so let's say that I'm
allowed 1,500 calories of food and these
are my options I have to go about
deciding looking at this food and it's
interesting again there's things showing
up on your screen that are not showing
up on my screen but they're harmless
things like how my mouse works any rate
so I'm trying to take some fraction of
this food and it can't add up to more
than 1,500 calories
the problem might be that once I take
something that's fourteen hundred and
eighty-five calories I can't take
anything else or maybe 1200 calories and
everything else is more than 300 so once
I take one thing it constrains possible
solutions a greedy algorithm as we'll
see if not guaranteed to give me the
best answer all right let's look at a
formalization of it
so each item is represented by a pair
the value of the item and the weight of
the item and let's assume the knapsack
can accommodate items for the total
weight of no more than W I apologize for
the short variable names but they're
easier to fit on a slide finally we're
going to have a vector L of length n
representing the set of available items
this is assuming we have n items to
choose from so each element of the
vector represents an item okay so those
are the items we have and then another
vector V is going to indicate whether or
not an item was taken so essentially I'm
going to use a binary number to
represent the set of items I choose to
take for item three say if bit three is
zero I'm not taking the item if bit
three is one than I am taking the item
so it just shows I can now very nicely
represent what I've done by a single
vector of zeros and ones let me pause
for a second
it's any one of any questions about this
setup it's important to get this set up
because what we're going to see now
depends upon that setting in your head
okay so I've kind of used mathematics to
describe the backpack
and that's typically the way we deal
with these optimization problems we
start with some informal description and
then we translate them into a
mathematical representation so here it
is we're going to try and find a vector
V that maximizes the sum of V sub I
times I sub I now remember what I saw by
is the value of the item V sub I is
either 0 or 1 so if I didn't take the
item I'm multiplying its value by 0 so
it contributes nothing to the sum if I
did take the item I'm multiplying its
value by 1 so the value of the item gets
added to the sum so that tells me the
value of V and I want to get the most
valuable V I can get subject to the
constraint that if I look at the items
dot weight and multiply it by V the sum
of the weights is no greater than W so
I'm playing the same trick with the
values of multiplying each one by 0 or 1
and that's my constraint make sense all
right so now we have the problem
formalized let's how do we solve it well
the most obvious solution is brute force
enumerate all possible combinations of
items that have to say I generate all
subsets of the items that are available
I don't know why it says subjects here
but we should have said items let me fix
that
this is called the power set so the
power set of a set includes the empty
subset it includes the set that includes
everything and every thing in between so
subsets of size 1 subsets of size 2 etc
so now I've generated all possible sets
of items I can now go through and sum up
the weights and remove all those sets
that weigh more than I'm allowed and
then from the remaining combinations
choose anyone whose value is the largest
I say choose any one because there could
be ties in which case I don't care which
I choose so it's pretty obvious that
this is going to give you a correct
answer you're considering all
possibilities and choosing a winner
unfortunately it's usually not very
practical what we see here is that's
what the power set is if you have a
hundred vector not very practical right
even for a fast computer generating that
many possibilities is going to take a
rather long time so kind of
disappointing we look at it and say well
we got a brute-force algorithm it will
solve the problem but it'd take too long
we can't actually do it 100 is pretty
small number right we often end up
solving optimization problems where n is
something closer to a thousand sometimes
even a million clearly boot force isn't
going to work so that raises the next
question are we just being stupid is
there a better algorithm that I should
have showed you I shouldn't say we
and I just being stupid is there a
better algorithm that would have given
us the answer a sad answer to that is no
for the knapsack problem and indeed many
optimization problems are inherently
exponential
what that means is there is no algorithm
that provides an exact solution to this
problem
whose worst-case running time is not
exponential in the number of items all
right it is an exponentially hard
problem it there is no really good
solution but that should not make you
sad because while there's no perfect
solution we're going to look at a couple
of really very good solutions that will
make this poor woman a happier person so
let's start with the greedy algorithm I
already talked to you about greedy
algorithms so it could hardly be simpler
we say while the knapsack is not full
put the best available item into the
knapsack when it's full we're done you
do need to ask a question what does best
mean is the best item the most valuable
is it the least expensive in terms of
say the fewest calories in my case or is
it the highest ratio of value to units
now maybe I think a calorie in a glass
of beer is worth more than a calorie in
a bar of chocolate maybe vice versa
which gets me to a concrete example so
you're about to sit down to a meal you
know how much you value the various
different foods for example maybe you
like doughnuts more than you like apples
you have a calorie budget and here we're
going to have a fairly austere budget
it's only one meal it's not the whole
day of 750 calories and we're going to
have to go through menus and choose what
to eat that is as we've seen a knapsack
problem they should probably have a
knapsack solver at every McDonald's and
Burger King
so here's a menu I just made up of wine
beer pizza burger fries coke apples and
a doughnut and the value I might place
on each of these and the number of
calories that actually are in each of
these and we're going to build a program
that will find an optimal menu and if
you don't like this menu you can run the
program and change the values to be
whatever you like well as you saw if you
took six triple zero one we like to
start with an abstract data type like to
organize our program around data
abstractions so I've got this class food
I can initialize things I have a get
value a get cost density which is going
to be the value divided by the cost and
then a string representation so nothing
here that you should not all be very
familiar with then I'm going to have a
function called build menu which will
take in a list of names and a list of
values of equal length and a list of
calories they're all the same length and
it will build the menu ok so it's going
to be a menu of tuples of a menu of
foods rather and I build each food by
giving it its name its value in its
caloric content now I have a menu now
comes the fun part here's an
implementation of a greedy algorithm I
called it a flexible greedy primarily
because of this key function over here
so you'll notice in red there's a
parameter called key function
that's going to be map the elements of
items to numbers so it will be used to
sort the items so I want to sort them
from best to worse and this function
will be used to tell me what I mean by
best
so maybe key function will just return
the value or maybe it will return the
weight or maybe it will return some
function of the destined of the density
but the idea here is I want to use one
greedy algorithm independently of my
definition of best so I use key function
to define what I mean by best so I'm
going to come in I'm going to sort it
from best to worse and then for I in
range Len of items sub copy I'm being
good I've copied it that's why you
sorted rather than sort I don't want to
have a side-effect in the parameter in
general it's not good hygiene to do that
and so for I'll go through it in order
from best to worst and if the value is
less than the maximum cost if putting it
in would keep me under the cost or not
over the cost I put it in and I just do
that until I can't put anything else in
so I might skip with you because I might
get to the point where there's only a
few calories left and the next best item
is over that budget but maybe further
down I'll find one that is not over it
and put it in okay that's why I can't
exit as soon as I reach as soon as I
find an item that won't fit and then
I'll just return this make sense
anyone have any doubts about whether
this algorithm actually works
I hope not because I think it does work
let's ask the next question how
efficient do we think it is what is the
efficiency of this algorithm well let's
see where the time goes see algorithm we
just looked at so the I deleted the
comment so we'd have a little more room
in the slide who wants to make a guess
by the way this is the question so
please go answer the questions you'll
see how people do but we can think about
it as well together well let's see where
the time goes the first thing is at the
sort so I'm going to sort all the items
and we heard from Professor Grimson how
long the sort takes see who remembers
Python uses something called Tim sort
which is a variant of something called
quicksort which has the same worst-case
complexity as merge sort and so we know
that is n log n where n in this case
would be the Len of items
okay so we know we have that then we
have a loop how many times we go through
this loop well we go through the loop n
times once for each item because we do
end up looking at every item and if we
know that what's the order
n log n plus n which is order n log n
right so it's pretty efficient and we
can do this for big numbers
like a million right log of a million
times a million is not a very big number
so it's very efficient
alright here's some code that uses
greedy takes in the items the constraint
in this case will be the weight and just
calls greedy but with the key function
and principle we have
so we're going to test greedy's I
actually think I use 750 in the code but
we can use 800 it doesn't matter and
here's something we haven't seen before
so use greedy by value to allocate and
calls test greedy with food max units
and food get value notice it's passing
the function that's why it's not know
close parenthesis after it use greedy
allocate it and then we have something
pretty interesting what's going on with
this lambda so here we're going to be
using greedy by density to allocate
actually sorry this is greedy by cost
and you'll notice what we're doing is we
don't want to pass in the cost right
because we really want the opposite of
the cost right we want we're going to
reverse the sort because we want the
cheaper items to get chosen first the
ones that have fewer calories not the
ones that have more calories as it
happens when I defined cost I defined it
in the obvious way the total number of
calories so I could have gone and
written another function to do it but
since it was so simple I decided to do
it inline so let's talk about lambda and
then come back to it lambda is used to
create an anonymous function anonymous
in the sense that it has no name so you
start with the keyword lambda you then
give it a sequence of identifiers x' and
then some expression what lambda does is
it builds a function that evaluates that
expression on those parameters and
returns the result of evaluating the
expression so instead of writing death
I have in line defined a function so if
we go back to it here you can see that
what I've done is lambda x1 divided by
food get cost of X notice food is the
class name here so I'm taking the
function get cost from the class food
and I'm passing it the parameter X which
is going to be what what's the type of X
going to be
I can wait you out what is the type of X
have to be for this lambda expression to
make sense well go back to the class
food what's the type of the argument of
get cost what's the name of the argument
to get cost that's an easier question
all right we'll go back and we'll look
at it
what's the type of the argument to get
cost food thank you so I do have
speaking of food we do have a tradition
in this class that people who answer
questions correctly get rewarded with
food Oh
Napoli would have caught that all right
so it has to be of type food right
because itself in the class food
so if we go back to here this X has to
be of type food right and sure enough
when we use it it will be let's now use
it I should point out that Landvik can
be really handy as it is here and it's
possible to write amazing beautiful
complicated lambda expressions and back
in the good old days of six double O one
people learned to do that and then they
learned that they shouldn't my view on
lambda expressions as if I can't fit it
in a single line I just go write deaf
and write a function definition because
it's easier to debug
but for one-liner it's lambda is great
alright let's look at using greedy so
here's this function test greedy takes
foods in the maximum number of units and
it's going to go through and it's going
to test all three greedy algorithms and
we just saw that and then here is the
call of it and so I picked up some names
and the values this is just the menu we
saw I'm going to build the menus and I'm
going to call tests Reedy's so let's go
look at the code that does this
so here you have it or maybe you don't
because every time I switch applications
the windows decides that I don't want to
show you the screen anyway this really
shouldn't be necessary
keep changes why keeps forgetting I
don't know anyway so here's the code
it's all the code we just looked at now
let's run it
well what we see here is that we use
greedy by value to allocate 7 or 50
calories and it chooses a burger the
pizza and the wine for a total of a
value of 284 that's happiness points if
you will on the other hand if we use
greedy by cost I get 318 happiness
points and a different menu the Apple
the wine the cold beer in the donut I've
lost the pizza in the burger I guess
this is what I signed up for when I put
my preferences on oh and here's another
solution with 318 apple wine oh yeah
alright so I actually got the same
solution but it just found them in a
different order right why did it find
minute in order because the sort order
was different because in this case I was
sorting by density so from this we see
an important point about greedy
algorithms right that we use the
algorithm and we got different answers
why do we have different answers the
problem is that a greedy algorithm makes
a sequence of local optimizations
chooses the locally optimal answer at
every point and that doesn't necessarily
add up to a globally optimal answer this
is often illustrated by showing an
example of say hill climbing so imagine
you're in a terrain looks something like
this
and you want to get to the highest point
you can get so you might choose as a
greedy algorithm if you can go up go up
if you can't go up you stop right so
whenever you get a choice you go up and
so if I start here I could right in the
middle maybe say all right it's not up
but it's not down either so I'll go
either left or right and let's say I go
right so I come to here then I'll just
make my way up to the top of the hill
making a locally optimal decision head
up at each point and I'll get here and
I'll say well now any place I go takes
me to a lower point so I don't want to
do it right because the greedy algorithm
says never go backwards so I'm here and
I'm happy on the other hand if I had
gone here for my first step then my next
step up would take me up up up I get to
here and I'd stop and say okay no way to
go but down I don't want to go down I'm
done and what I would find is I'm at a
local maximum rather than a global
maximum and that's the problem with
greedy algorithms that you can get stuck
at a local optimal point and not get to
the best one now we could ask the
question what can I just say don't worry
about a density say will always get me
the best answer will true I've tried a
different experiment let's say I'm
feeling expansive and I'm going to allow
myself a thousand calories
well here what we see is the winner will
be greedy by value happens to find a
better answer for 24 instead of for 13
so there is no way to know in advance
sometimes this definition of best might
work sometimes that might work sometimes
no definition bail vest will work and
you can't get to a good solution or you
get to a good solution you can't get to
an optimal solution with the greedy
algorithm on Wednesday we'll talk about
how do you actually guarantee finding an
optimal solution in a better way than
brute force see you then